let's face it we could all use a getaway
right now i'm britt moran founder and
ceo of britain co
and i've teamed up with dq to welcome
you to fandango's family movie night
so today i'm showing you how to add some
far away fun to your kids blocks
so they can build the city of their
dreams inspired by some of their
favorite films
to get started you'll just need three
simple things kids blocks
paint pens or markers and washi tape you
can choose to have metallic washi tape
and matte washi tape start by stacking
your blocks to create the perfect city
block shapes
i like to stack my blocks just like this
on top of each other now it's time to
decorate your box
to get started you can use your washi
tape to just wrap around the edges and
create nice borders
or if you need to bind your blocks
together to make one big shape
you can even make a fun grid pattern
just like this with your washi tape and
then to take it to the
next level use your paint pins to create
little borders
or decorations on the blocks themselves
i'm going to use polka dots for mine
dream house done when can i come visit
and does your new wooden neighborhood of
a dq so i can grab a blizzard treat from
the new dq fall blizzard menu on my way
thank you so much for watching and check
out your local dq for the new caramel
apple pie blizzard treat and other new
flavors see you next time